fueling and daily maintenance on
tractors and other farm equipment has
the potential for serious accidents
operators should start by checking
operator manuals for specific safety
practices become familiar with symbols
and colors on equipment intended to warn
operators of danger points and
activities red color is associated with
danger it indicates Ates a hazardous
situation which if not heated can result
in death orange color is associated with
hazardous situations which if not heated
can result in serious injury or death
yellow color indicates a hazardous
situation which if not avoided can
result in minor or moderate
injury read all safety decals on the
machine and follow the instructions
before starting operating refueling or
performing any mainten on the machine
remember to keep a first aid kit in each
tractor or self-propelled machine the
operator's manual explains which fluids
need to be checked daily and how to do
the checks operator's manuals also
include safety tips and describe the
location and purpose of all of the
gauges and controls as well as other
indicators knowing where the controls
are by memory can allow operators to
react more quickly in emergency
situations the operator's manual will
also explain the correct safety
procedures for refueling tractors and
self-propelled farm equipment only
refuel tractors and farm machinery when
the engine is cool and shut
off never smoke while refueling
equipment if you have to climb a ladder
to reach the fuel tank be particularly
careful if the steps are wet or icy all
fuels are flammable so be careful to
minimize activities that could ignite
the fuel during the refueling avoid
overfilling fuel tanks any fuel spills
should be immediately cleaned up
tractors and equipment with Selective
catalytic reduction or scr emission
reduction technology require filling a
second fuel tank with diesel exhaust
fluid check the fluid levels in the
engine crank case radiator and
transmission daily be particularly
careful when checking radiator levels
because the radiator is pressurized when
the engine is hot proper tire pressure
is important when operating tractors on
roads and in working
operations inflate each tire according
to the tire manufacturer's
recommendations inflation requirements
may be located on the outside of the
tire around the rim and in the tractor's
operator manual power hop also called
wheel hop Tire hop or tractor hop is a
condition of tractors and self-propelled
farm equipment bouncing while operated
on highways power hop is caused by
overinflated tires remember to check for
cuts cracks and bruises in all Equipment
Tires check to make sure all headlights
flashers and brake lights are working
correctly clean and visible to other
drivers farm tractors are required to
have two forward-facing headlights and a
red tail light that burn continuously
the tail light must be visible from 500
ft under normal conditions and mounted
on the left rear side of the the tractor
farm tractors and Equipment require
Hazard warning lights or flashers when
operating on public roads white or Amber
flashers are mounted on the front and
red or Amber on the rear these lights
must be activated when the vehicle is in
operation clean clear windows and clean
mirrors are essential for good Vision
while operating tractors take the time
to properly adjust the mirrors check
Shields around the engine to make sure
they are securely fastened and in good
condition following safety precautions
does take a little more
time but being safe is your number one
commodity